[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans la grande
interview nous sommes d'ici là genève au
siège européen des nations unies pour
rencontrer tatiana ivanova ya directrice
générale de l'office des nations unies
de genève
bonjour madame van hove aya merci
beaucoup de nous recevoir ici à genève
au siège des nations unies madame van
hove aya vous avez été nommé en mai 2019
directrice générale de l'office des
nations unies par antonio guterres est
ce vous avez succédé à michael miller
jusqu'à présent comment avez vous vécu
ses premiers mois au sein de l'onu à 27
c'est un travail passionnant je voudrais
dire que j'ai déjà beaucoup travaillé
avec l'onu avec d'autres organisations
de la famille de la one-77 une fois en
son sein qu'on comprend vraiment
l'ampleur de ce que l'onu fait il faut
vraiment plus communiquer sur nos
activités et comment ils touchent la vie
des citoyens ordinaires et c'est un
travail passionnant
vous avez débuté votre carrière comme
journaliste à moscou comment passe-t-on
de journalistes à directrice générale de
l'office des nations unies de genève est
ce que vous pouvez pas nous parler un
peu de votre parcours j'ai suivi des
études d'économie
je suis diplômé de l'institut des
finances avec une spécialité en
relations économiques internationales
bottes aeroflot mais j'ai préféré me
lancer dans une carrière de journaliste
car mon père était un grand journaliste
à l'époque j'ai continué ma carrière
universitaire je suis devenu spécialiste
de l'intégration européenne
j'ai écrit et publié un livre sur le
sujet et lorsque l'union soviétique a
ouvert sa première mission diplomatique
à bruxelles la commission européenne
économique
ils ont cherché des experts de
l'intégration européenne c'est ce livre
qui leur a permis de trouver et on m'a
proposé un poste dans la délégation
soviétique à bruxelles
j'ai donc commencé par travailler pour
le ministère des affaires étrangères
puis au retour de bruxelles
j'ai travaillé pour le gouvernement de
la fédération de russie qui a été
également chargé des affaires
internationales et c'est comme ça qu'a
commencé ma carrière administrative
depuis la création des nations désunies
nous avons dû attendre 2009 pour voir
une femme à la tête de ce bureau est ce
que l'on peut parler de révolution à un
pied je suis la treizième personne à ce
poste de direction générale de l'office
des nations unies à genève le bureau
nous ne trouvons était celui du
secrétaire général de la ligue des
nations unies nous en avons
effectivement je suis la 13ème à ce
poste et je suis la première femme de
fos truman soya souhaite trouver en
effet il a fallu attendre deux ans vous
verrez
et si le résultat d'efforts importants
du secrétaire général antonio gutiérrez
lenteur et notes afin d'atteindre la
parité à la direction de différents
organes des nations unies
mais je dois dire qu'ici à genève
numériquement à odza nous avons déjà
pratiquement atteint la parité à tous
les niveaux de l'administration
aussi à une époque où les populations
sont concernés par le changement
climatique est une question et les
questions en général allié à l'écologie
selon vous à l'onu at-elle un rôle à
jouer et comment hassine z6 ouais je
pense que c'est l'onu qui a mobilisé ce
mouvement mondial contre le changement
climatique à deux fois l'urgence
climatique et je pense que le secrétaire
général antonio gutiérrez a joué un rôle
remarquable avec les nombreux sommets
qu'il a organisées dans le monde entier
sur le changement climatique
hal est tous des cités et je pense que
c'est grâce à cela qu'il y a une
conscience publique de la nécessité de
la lutte contre le changement climatique
et l'onu a fourni beaucoup d'efforts et
a beaucoup d'atouts dans ce domaine
d'autres à weekend hayoz nous pouvons
appliquer la recherche scientifique week
end nous pouvons continuer nos efforts
pour mobiliser le secteur privé afin de
rendre la façon de faire des affaires
plus durable et d'amour au stand nous
pouvons être très efficace dans la
mobilisation des citoyens ordinaires au
de recettes
nous disposons d'un écosystème unique
nous avons les institutions de l'onu
nous avons le secteur privé nous avons
beaucoup d'organisations internationales
des ong
nous pouvons accomplir beaucoup de
choses l'année dernière par exemple nous
avons accueilli une semaine thématique
organisée par la communauté financière
et nous mêmes sur le financement du
développement durable c'est l'une des
questions clés comment trouver les
ressources comment trouver les fonds
pour financer le développement durable
en tant que directrice générale de
l'office des nations unies de genève
et quel est le plus grand défi auquel
vous êtes confrontés à ces agapes et
est-il le plus grand défi pour moi mais
aussi pour tous les directeurs
d'organisations internationales d'office
internationaux au fait c est ce à taux
est faible c'est d'améliorer la
communication l'intégration avec les
citoyens ordinaires
actuellement ce n'est pas suffisant
l'onu a besoin du soutien des citoyens
ordinaires hors cote
mais pour cela il faut répondre à leurs
aspirations a les idées pour nous la
coopération est primordial nous ne
sommes pas une bureaucratie
nous ne voulons pas l'être oui les
premiers mots de la charte des nations
unies sont nous peuples des nations
unies et non de cette bêta afin d'être
l'organisation de ces peuples
nous devons être davantage à leur écoute
et accomplir ce qu'il vous demande de
faire taire la sto
vous avez pris la tête des nations unies
de genève à une époque où le
multilatéralisme n'est pas très en vogue
comment est ce que vous pouvez expliquer
ce rejet exact le multilatéralisme et la
cible d'attaqué sna
pourquoi c'est un problème majeur de big
east problème non aux anneaux défi
aujourd'hui sont planétaires
le changement climatique est un défi
planétaire le développement économique
et social est un défi planétaire à nous
avons besoin de solutions planétaire de
solutions multilatérales et bien sûr le
multilatéralisme et suit des attaques
exacte et la raison c'est ce fossé entre
les élites gouvernantes au niveau
national ou international et la
population ordinaire sont de tolstoï
nous devons restaurer la confiance entre
les citoyens ordinaires et les
organisations qui représentent leur
intérêt dont les organisations
internationales
peut-on parler selon vous d'une crise du
multilatéralisme
est ce une simple réorganisation à
croiser les crises ne sont que des défis
les crises nous pousse à trouver de
nouvelles solutions famille retourne à
mon sens la crise actuelle et la crise
du multilatéralisme du 20e siècle
odette 900 mais cela représente
également la possibilité d'une
transition
vers un nouveau multilatéralisme le
multilatéralisme du 21e siècle un visa
quoi pourrait-il ressembler mb quelle
serait la différence avec ceux qui le
remplacerait au 20e siècle le système
multilatéral manqué d'inclusivité ce
système des boîtes de nombreuses nations
de nombreux pays sentait qu'ils
n'avaient pas voix au chapitre
il s'agirait d'un système multilatéral à
toutes les nations tous les pays
quelle que soit leur taille leur
démographie leur pib pourrait se faire
entendre
j'ai dit oui d'autre part et c'est très
important
l'ancien système était conçu pour les
pays pour les gouvernements kinds of
garonne mais aujourd'hui les
organisations internationales
supranationale joue un rôle ses voeux le
secteur civil
les ong font aussi partie de ceux
multilatéralisme émergents emerging
cointreau secteur privé est également
prévu de cette baie kozmino fois car les
grandes sociétés opèrent partout dans le
monde et leur activité devrait elle
aussi être inscrite dans la durabilité
des choses à prendre en compte les
aspirations et les besoins des citoyens
ce nouveau système multilatéral devrait
être inclusif de tout point de vue un
acte scop en matière d'acteur mais
également en offrant la possibilité à
tous elle passe bel été tous les pays
tous des nations tous les citoyens de se
faire entendre
m cette décote est ce qu'il y à une
alternative au multilatéralisme selon
vous il n'y a pas d'alternative au
multilatéralisme
mais le multilatéralisme est en période
de transition
donc nous devons réfléchir à sa mise en
place afin qu'il soit durable et
inclusif été tués
vous avez commencé à travailler au
gouvernement russe en 1989 en tant qu
ancien diplomate aujourd'hui quels sont
vos axes d'effort en matière de
diplomatie pendant votre mandat
je dirige une représentation des nations
unies je ne représente pas le
gouvernement russe où aucun autre
je suis fonctionnaire international pour
nous cela signifie travailler pour tout
le monde pour leurs idées pour les
nations unies pour mon portefeuille
couvre des domaines très large dont le
désarmement je suis aussi secrétaire
général de la conférence du désarmement
qui est basé ici à genève
nous collaborons avec d'autres
organisations pour le développement
durable prod sur de nombreux projets
pour l'éducation et l'office de l'onu à
genève est un important centre de
conférences
saft et les nations unies vont célébrer
à leur 75e anniversaire
pour l'occasion l'organisation a lancé
une gigantesque campagne incluant un
dialogue mondial
est ce que c'est important d'inclure
tous les citoyens dans les discussions
est ce que pour vous c'est la clé of
causse mais quoi bien sûr c'est
justement pour cela qu'il a été décidé
d'organiser plus qu'une simple fête sang
froid car bien que nous ayons de quoi
faire une fête car au cours des 75
dernières années ce sont les nations
unies qui ont préservé la paix et la
sécurité
nous n'avons plus de conflit mondial
quoi au fait nous avons eu beaucoup de
succès dans la lutte contre la pauvreté
à mener et nous avons amélioré la vie
des gens il y a de nombreuses raisons de
célébrer bateau et décède et notes mais
nous avons décidé plutôt d'initier une
conversation internationale sur l'avenir
que nous voulons et les nations unies
dont nous avons besoin de se soigner et
hôpitaux different à un pathos nous
allons nous adresser à tous les segments
de la société en priorité à la jeunesse
un stress donc dallas cowboys & you
because of parce qu'il faut écouter les
jeunes jambes mais pas ici dans le monde
entier d'innombrables jeunes militants
et lutte contre le changement climatique
pour le développement durable pour les
droits de l'homme human rights award et
devons nous adresser à ces jeunes qui
seront les meneurs de demain savoir
comment ils conçoivent cet avenir est ce
que l'onu peut accomplir d'un art
question selon vous ce dialogue global
c'est la clé pour accroître la longévité
l'onu orkos pkoi et bien sûr et neige
sont organisés toute organisation
internationale doit changer pour trouver
des solutions aux nouveaux défis
mondiaux
stony brook shields bateau vos dvd mais
au fil des années l'organisation a prêté
de plus en plus d'attention au
développement social et économique à la
lutte contre les inégalités à
l'éducation à la préservation des sites
et du patrimoine culturel
à sète comme je les dis nous devons
mieux communiquer et réfléchir à des
façons de rendre notre action plus
efficace
perso il faut changer nous avons un plan
de route ce sont les 17 objectifs du
programme pour le développement durable
c'est inédit pour la première fois nous
avons un plan soutenu par l'ensemble des
états membres qui nous mène jusqu'à 2030
comment améliorer l'éducation nous la
santé
comment éradiquer la pauvreté comment
garantir l'égalité des genres comment
s'assurer que tout c'est un emploi
décent
comment préserver la nature comment
former des partenariats et ses recettes
nous avons cette feuille de route pour
l'appliquer il faut renforcer
l'efficacité de notre organisation et de
notre travail
c'est pourquoi nous avons besoin de
retour de la part des peuples du monde
entier et je souhaiterais demandé à tous
de se rendre sur le site de l'onu et de
remplir un sondage très rapide c'est
ainsi que nous pouvons tous prendre part
à cette conversation mondiale
merci beaucoup à madame van hove iia de
nous avoir reçus ici au siège des
nations unies à genève
c'est la fin de cette grande interview
merci de l'avoir suivi une émission que
vous pouvez retrouver sur notre site
internet à l'adresse arte france pour tv
[Musique]